so this is a talk about
gene drives i'm going to start by
telling you a brief story
20 years ago a biologist named anthony
james
got obsessed with the idea of making
mosquitoes that didn't
transmit malaria it was a great idea
and pretty much a complete failure for
one thing
it turned out to be really hard to make
a malaria-resistant mosquito
james managed it finally just a few
years ago
by adding some genes that make it
impossible for the malaria parasite to
survive inside the mosquito
but that just created another problem
now that you've got a malaria resistant
mosquito
how do you get it to replace all the
malaria-carrying mosquitoes
there were a couple options but plan a
was basically to breed up
a bunch of the new genetically
engineered mosquitoes release them into
the wild
and hope that they pass on their genes
the problem
was that you'd have to release literally
ten times the number of native
mosquitoes for that to work
so in a village with ten thousand
mosquitoes you'd release an extra
hundred thousand as you might guess this
was not a very popular strategy with the
villagers
then last january anthony james got an
email
from a biologist named ethan beer beer
said that he and his grad student
valentino gans
had stumbled on a tool that could not
only guarantee that a particular genetic
trait would be inherited
but that would spread incredibly quickly
if they were right it would basically
solve the problem that james had been
working on for 20 years
as a test they engineered two mosquitoes
to carry the anti-malaria gene
and also this new tool a gene drive
which i'll explain in a minute
finally they set it up so that any
mosquitoes that inherited the
anti-malaria gene
wouldn't have the usual white eyes but
would instead have
red eyes that was pretty much just for
convenience they could tell at a glance
which was which
so they took their two anti-malarial
red-eyed mosquitoes put them in a box
with 30 ordinary white eyed ones
and let them breed in two generations
those had produced
3 800 grandchildren that is not the
surprising part
this is a surprising part given that you
started with just
two red-eyed mosquitoes and 30 wide-eyed
ones you'd expect
mostly wide-eyed descendants instead
when james opened the box all 3800
mosquitoes
had red eyes when i asked ethan beer
about this moment
he became so excited that he was
literally shouting into the phone
that's because getting only red eyed
mosquitoes violates a rule that is the
absolute cornerstone of biology
mendelian genetics i'll keep this quick
but mendelian genetics says that when a
male and female mate
their baby inherits half of its dna from
each parent
so if our original mosquito is a a and
our new mosquito is a b
or b is the anti-malaria gene the baby
should come out in four permutations
a a a b a a b a
instead with a new gene drive they all
came out a b
biologically that shouldn't even be
possible so what happened
the first thing that happened was the
arrival of a gene editing tool known as
crispr
in 2012. many of you have probably heard
about crispr
so i'll just say briefly that crispr is
a tool that allows researchers to edit
genes very precisely
and easily and quickly it does this by
harnessing a mechanism that already
existed in bacteria
basically there's a protein that acts
like a scissors and cuts the dna
and there's an rna molecule that directs
the scissors to any point on the genome
you want
the result is basically a word processor
for genes
you can take an entire gene out put one
in or even edit just a single letter
within a gene
and you can do it in nearly any species
okay remember how i said that gene
drives originally had two problems
the first was that it was hard to
engineer a mosquito
to be malaria resistant that's basically
gone now thanks to crispr
but the other problem was logistical how
do you get your trait to spread
this is where it gets clever a couple
years ago
a biologist at harvard named kevin
espelt wondered what would happen if you
made it so that crispr inserted
not only your new gene but also the
machinery that does the cutting and
pasting
in other words what if crispr also
copied and pasted itself
you'd end up with a perpetual motion
machine for gene editing
and that's exactly what happens this
crispr gene drive that s felt created
not only guarantees that a trait will
get passed on
but if it's used in the germline cells
it will automatically
copy and paste your new gene into both
chromosomes of every single individual
it's like a global search and replace or
in science terms it makes a heterozygous
trait homozygous
so what does this mean for one thing it
means that we have a very
powerful but also somewhat alarming new
tool
up until now the fact that gene drives
didn't work very well was actually kind
of a relief
normally when we mess around with an
organism's genes we make that thing
less evolutionarily fit so biologists
can make all the mutant fruit flies they
want without worrying about it
if some escape natural selection just
takes care of them
what's remarkable and powerful and
frightening about gene drives
is that that will no longer be true
assuming that your trait does not have a
big evolutionary handicap like a
mosquito that can't fly
the crispr crispr-based gene drive will
spread the change relentlessly
until it is in every single individual
in the population
now it isn't easy to make a gene drive
that works that well but james and
asfelt think that we can
the good news is that this opens the
door to some remarkable things
if you put an anti-malarial gene drive
in just one percent of anopheles
mosquitoes
the species that transmits malaria
researchers estimate that it would
spread to the entire population
in a year so in a year you could
virtually eliminate malaria
in practice we're still a few years out
from being able to do that but still
a thousand children a day die of malaria
in a year that number could be almost
zero
the same goes for dengue fever
chikungunya yellow fever
and it gets better say you want to get
rid of an invasive species
like get asian carp out of the great
lakes
all you have to do is release a gene
drive that makes the fish produce only
male
offspring in a few generations there'll
be no females left
no more carp in theory this means we
could restore hundreds of native species
that have been pushed to the brink
okay that's the good news
this is the bad news gene drives are so
effective
that even an accidental release could
change an entire species
and often very quickly anthony james
took good precautions
he bred his mosquitoes in a
biocontainment lab and he also used a
species that's not native to the us
so that even if some did escape they'd
just die off there'd be nothing for them
to mate with
but it's also true that if a dozen asian
carp with the all-male gene drive
accidentally got carried from the great
lakes back to asia
they could potentially wipe out the
native asian carp population
and that's not so unlikely given how
connected our world is in fact it's why
we have an invasive species problem and
that's
fish things like mosquitoes and fruit
flies
there's literally no way to contain them
they cross borders and oceans
all the time okay
the other piece of bad news is that a
gene drive might not stay confined to
what we call
the target species that's because of
gene flow which is basically a fancy way
of saying that neighboring species
sometimes interbreed
if that happens it's possible a gene
drive could cross over like
asian carp could infect some other kind
of carp that's not so bad if your drive
just promotes a trait
like eye color in fact there's a decent
chance that we'll see a wave of very
weird fruit flies in the near future
but it could be a disaster if your drive
is designed to eliminate the species
entirely
the last worrisome thing is that the
technology to do this
to genetically engineer an organism and
include a gene drive
is something that basically any lab in
the world can do
an undergraduate can do it a talented
high schooler
with some equipment can do it
now i'm guessing that this sounds
terrifying
interestingly though nearly every
scientist i talked to seemed to think
that gene drives were not actually that
frightening or dangerous
partly that's because they believe that
scientists will be very cautious and
responsible about using them
so far that's been true but gene tribes
also have some actual limitations so for
one thing they work only in sexually
reproducing species so
thank goodness they can't be used to
engineer viruses or bacteria
also the trait spreads only with each
successive generation
so changing or eliminating a population
is practical only if that species has a
fast reproductive
cycle like insects or maybe small
vertebrates like mice and fish
in elephants or people it would take
centuries for a trait to spread widely
enough to matter
also even with crispr it's not that easy
to engineer a truly devastating trait
say you wanted to make a fruit fly that
feeds on ordinary fruit instead of
rotting fruit with the aim of sabotaging
american agriculture
first you'd have to figure out which
genes control what the fruit fly wants
to eat
which is already a very long and
complicated project
then you'd have to alter those genes to
change the fly's behavior
to wherever you want it to be which is
an even longer and more complicated
project
and it might not even work because the
genes that control behavior are complex
so if you're a terrorist and have to
choose between starting a grueling basic
research program that will require years
of meticulous lab work
and still might not pan out or just
blowing stuff up
you'll probably choose a letter this is
especially true because at least in
theory it should be pretty
easy to build what's called a reversal
drive that's one that basically
overwrites the change made by the first
gene drive
so if you don't like the effects of a
change you can just release a second
drive that will cancel it out
at least in theory
okay so where does this leave us
we now have the ability to change entire
species at will
should we are we gods now i'm not sure
i'd say that
but i would say this first
some very smart people are even now
debating how to regulate gene drives
at the same time some other very smart
people are working hard to create
safeguards
like gene drives that self-regulate or
peter out after a few generations
that's great but this technology still
requires a conversation
and given the nature of gene drives that
conversation has to be global
what if kenya wants to use a drive but
tanzania doesn't
who decides whether to release a gene
drive that can fly
i don't have the answer to that question
all we can do going forward i think
is talk honestly about the risks and
benefits and take responsibility
for our choices by that i mean not just
the choice to use a gene drive
but also the choice not to use one
humans have a tendency to assume that
the safest option is to preserve the
status quo
but that's not always the case gene
drives have risks
and those need to be discussed but
malaria exists now
and kills a thousand people a day to
combat it we spray pesticides that do
grave damage to other species including
amphibians and birds
so when you hear about gene drives in
the coming months and trust me you will
be hearing about them
remember that it can be frightening to
act
but sometimes not acting as worse
you